okay so this is the Rubik's Cube
tutorial and this is the second step we
left off with finishing the bottom cross
the white cross in which these white
edge pieces were matched with their
respective centers as far as the the
white orange is matched with the orange
and also the white blue with the blue
white with the white the white red edge
piece is matched with red and white and
also the green and white so the next
step that we have to do is going to be
to complete the bottom color by placing
the four white corner pieces and by
corner piece I mean a piece that has
three different colors on it and it has
to have white on it because we want to
put the white ones down here and once
we're done this whole bottom should be
the it will be a white color so what you
have to do first is you want to look on
the top layer you want to look on the
side here just as we did for the white
edge pieces in the first step you want
to look on the top four pieces that have
a white color on the side as you can see
there are none here but you do see two
on top that have white but it's on the
top it's facing towards the ceiling
which is not the way we want it so we're
going to have to correct this and in
order to do that you're going to have to
memorize a move which is it's able to be
done on the right side and also the left
side so it's just basically a reflection
of itself and the move is right
clockwise top 180 right back down and by
doing that move you now see that you
have two white corner pieces which have
a white side a white color on the side
and this is exactly how we want it to
look we want
this white corner piece to be on the top
and we also want it so that there is a
white the white color is on the side so
if we do not want it like this
this is this white color is on top it's
on the top the up face of the cube we
want it to be on a side face either the
front back left or right so these two
are okay and then what you do is you
could start with either one we'll start
with this one you look at the other
color that is on the adjacent side to
the white in this case it's blue
you don't look at the top color which is
red and what you do you match this blue
side with its color diagonally and by
doing that you're able to put that piece
down and what I mean by matching it
diagonally I mean you have to turn the
top layer this top layer until that blue
side the blue color is matched
diagonally as as like it is here then
once you do that you hold this blue side
and you do the following move you do
right clockwise top clockwise right
counterclockwise and what that does is
it places this this corner piece between
a three corner of the three colors that
it has to be matched to which are white
red and blue let me do that move one
more time I also like to call it so if
it's on the right side you can say up
towards you and back down so let's do
the other piece now so we also have a
blue a blue corner that is a white
corner piece that has blue on it and
also orange so we're also only looking
at the blue color now because that's on
the side with the white it's on the
adjacent side and what you do is you
match that up diagonally with its Center
so just turn the top
until that blue is matched diagonally
with its center so now it's matched
diagonally and what you're going to do
now is you're going to do the reverse of
the move that we did on the right side
so it's left side counterclockwise top
counterclockwise left side clockwise and
you can see that this blue orange white
corner is matched in between the white
blue and the orange centers let me do
that little one more time so here's that
corner piece it's matched up with the
blue you go up bring it towards you so
that these whites meet up and then bring
it back down now we have two corner
pieces which are in the correct position
now there are two more that we need to
place one is down here and the other one
is up here
okay now that move that I said before
you're going to have to perform that and
you could do it one of two ways you can
do it so that you start with this corner
piece and you bring it this way or you
could do it so that you start with this
corner piece and bring it this way it
doesn't really matter so I'm going to
start I like to have it on the right
side so you do the move you go right
clockwise top 180 and right back down
and as you see what that does is it
makes this one now it has a white color
on the side so now you do the same thing
as before you look at the other color on
the side with the white in this case
it's green you match it up with its
center hold that Center and you go up
with that piece bring it towards you and
bring it back down also it's also like I
said before right side clockwise top
side clockwise right side
counterclockwise and there is one corner
left that we need to fix and when you're
doing the last corner you have to look
on the bottom because there is a open
but here what you need to do is you need
to put it so that this corner piece with
the white on it is directly below that
spot and if you don't what what will
happen is when you do that move to try
to fix this it will mess up this corner
that you had already placed it will mess
that up so you want to directly put this
piece directly above this empty spot
like so now it's directly above that
empty spot and you can perform that
other than the move again which which
fixes these corner pieces that have the
white on top it's up 180 and back down
then what you do now that this is fixed
you look at the other color again on the
side which is red match it with its
Center diagonally hold the center you go
up bring the white towards you so that
you match it with the other whites and
then you bring the whole side again back
down now you have the whole entire
bottom completed and as you'll see if
you turn the cue upside down you have
these color tees this one's green this
one's red this one's blue don't pay
attention to these edge pieces and this
one's orange and that completes the
second step of solving the puzzle